according to popular myth cockroaches
would inherit a post nuclear disaster
world but it looks like the real winners
might actually be funky in 1999 fungi
were found to be thriving in highly
radioactive conditions inside the
Chernobyl reactor these fungi are rich
in melanin yep the same stuff that gives
you a tan in summer while radiation
causes cell damage and mutations in most
living creatures melanin rich fungi are
actually attracted to the stuff and it
seems the spherical nature of the
melanin axis shield but it also allows
energy to be absorbed from the radiation
enhancing the fungus growth these fungi
may one day help clean up radioactive
waste or even lead to the development of
new cancer treatments but if there's a
nuclear accident in the meantime don't
panic right away that mushroom cloud
might not be what you think it is hey
everyone that's just a little segment
I've voiced for a Aussie TV show called
catalyst and actually I've been
travelling with this TV show for the
last five weeks in case you've been
wondering where I was and in fact I've
been traveling with two other people
Anja and Simon okay okay so we're doing
catalyst on the road which is actually a
road trip from Perth to Melbourne and
we've had an amazing time including
things like cave diving and catching
mullah ways and land sailing on a salt
lake so we've done some incredible stuff
and that's all going to go to air in
Australia on abc1 starting in February
if you want to check out their YouTube
channel you can look at it you put an
annotation here you can you can click
this and go to their YouTube channel and
if you're really nice to them maybe they
will post some of this episode some of
these episodes on their YouTube channel
besides that I will be back in Sydney
after Christmas and then I'll make some
more veritasium style stuff so stay
tuned for that that is disgusting
actually not believe it
go son